i uh i'm not kidding when i say i really
like the holidays you know usually at
this point in the show i cross over and
we
sit down and andy and i start acting
like fools but i wanted to talk about
christmas for just a second if i could i
love this time of year
i really do it's a very special holiday
to me and mostly and i think this is
true of for
a lot of you out there mostly because i
think back to when i was a kid
you know and you never forget that
excitement of waking up on christmas
morning and you're in your pajamas
and you run downstairs with your brother
or your sister and they're also in their
pajamas you run downstairs
and you see those gifts underneath the
tree for the first time
probably the most exciting moment in
childhood don't you think that's true
i definitely miss that i mean it you
know was that that compulsive
child energy yeah it was just fun it's
something that
he's right it's something that i don't
know that we kind of lose when we grow
older and well anyway i started thinking
there's a um
there's a big tree very famous the
rockefeller center tree
that's right out in front of this
building where we shoot the show liz can
we get a shot of it
right now there it is outside it's
beautiful it's world famous
that's pretty and i found out earlier
today
he has never been out there it's it's
pretty yeah
you act kind of surprised you hadn't
seen it i i heard about it
yeah yeah don't let them out a lot
really
well this gets me to my my next point uh
they
i heard that nbc put
a lot of really big expensive cool gifts
for all the nbc stars underneath that
tree
tonight did you hear about this there
there's presents for us
down yeah i mean they said for nbc stars
so
i would think that there might be a
presence for you and me under the tree
in fact i'm pretty sure there are well
then
why are we here exactly exactly my i
thought it's come on over here andy i
thought it'd be kind of cool tonight if
andy and i
oh we got him back yeah you're over here
honest
i'm his spot yeah isn't this nice hello
america
i thought it would be a nice christmas
present
if tonight andy and i we got in our
pajamas and we ran down there
and we saw what kind of presents they
have for us can we have some
taking off clothes music max
[Applause]
[Music]
it should probably be something a little
christmas yeah just the
the same thing with sleigh bells
[Applause]
i am so glad i remember to put pajamas
on under here
yeah they always they always give me the
footy ones
uh andy i think you look can't get
around andy turn around for the people
this this is what i'll be wearing when i
announce my new cologne
infantilized
[Applause]
i'm gonna buy it and i hope so it smells
like baby powder
all right i think we're all just about
set and all right
andy let's uh mentally put ourselves
back there when we were kids
it's christmas morning and we're gonna
run out down there
wait wait a minute wait a minute take
your riddling all right
we're gonna run down there and we're
gonna see what presents we got you ready
i'm ready one two three
sorry sorry sorry about that
hurry presents
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen uh little technical
problem here
you can't really take a camera on an
elevator because it has a cable cable
right here
andy and i are gonna get on the elevator
right now and you're gonna see a
blackout for about
15 20 seconds something like that then
you'll catch us at the bottom because we
can't have a camera in here we'll see
you next time in the lobby yeah bye-bye
god is anyone buying this bit why would
they i mean it's like the stupidest
thing we've ever done
i hate christmas
[Applause]
okay christmas
hey everybody how are you hey how you
doing
look guys we got to get to the christmas
tree really fast we're going to need
your help yeah we're going to need your
help yeah
thanks go okay
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
come on hurry oh hurry hurry
it's christmas everybody christmas
[Applause]
merry christmas everybody
hey how are you hey how you doing
hey oh man look at these presents
look at that this is so cool
it's a huge motorcycle look at that
it's a it's a motorcycle and it says
it's for it's for jerry seinfeld that's
so cool
oh and look there's a pony for george
clooney oh
george clooney got a pony i hope i get a
pony look this big box is for brook
shields brook shield what could it be
that must be something really leno got
one well where's lars
i don't know i don't know where ours is
i don't get it i don't see where it is
oh right here yeah these are ours
what do you think that means it's kind
of depressing
hey andy i tell you what look down here
come on look at this what is it
it's kelsey grammer's chainsaw that's so
cool
yes they're not gonna give us a nice
present let's take down the tree
all right all right folks we're gonna
we'll be right back with janine
garoppolo we'll see in a second stick
around